all right time for goats in a bad way
chris you've got the trivia question all
right cam newton had a career-low 23.6
passer rating in the patriots win over
the cardinals the lowest rating by any
starting quarterback to win a game
since 2012.
when another afc east qb
with a misleading nickname
also beat the cardinals
who
was that quarterback
or it had to have been mark sanchez
exactly
the sanchez
the sanchez baby that's amazing 10 for
21 for 97 yards zero tds three
interceptions
seven six thriller jets win
at first i thought it was a trick
question that maybe tim tebow
technically was the start of that game
but then i remembered the year he was
the jets like they never let him off the
sideline except to be like the
the punt protector remember like they
they they traded for him and never
actually used it they didn't know what
to do with them all right goats in a bad
way i get the first pick i am gonna
start with
i guess i gotta start and i'm influenced
by
uh
last night's game i carson wentz i i i
don't i just don't get it i was on with
rich eisen yesterday and he asked me a
question chris and maybe you know the
answer to it because i couldn't think of
anyone has there been a quarterback
in the last 20 years
where
he comes in plays well checks the boxes
gets paid
looks like a franchise guy and just
loses it it's just gone i can't think of
another guy that that's happened to it's
definitely happened to carson wentz so
he's my first pick yeah well it i mean
it is but as we've talked about it's the
whole organization has gone down since
then too so it's more than that and you
know you saw during the show already
hey the fact that he carried the team
last year
it really probably hurt him this year
because they go oh wait we're not that
bad our team lay we just stay healthy if
al shawn and deshawn can stay healthy
we'll be different oh wait no we're in
the same boat and it's all the same
again and it's even worse and it's uh it
is it's frustrating i feel bad i feel
bad for carson wentz um i i'm i'm going
with the whole colts defense i don't
care all right there are goats in a bad
way this week the colts defense i mean
they went into the weekend as the number
two defense in football they got
shellacked and i know there's no
deforest buckner but i don't know i just
can't give you a free pass with the way
the tennessee titans just bludgeoned you
in the run game and aj brown running all
over the field that was just a bad
effort all together so the colts colts d
will be my first goats in a bad way
next one for me since we were talking
about it earlier and he was taking one
pick before carson wentz and it's
possible that both guys who got paid end
up being damn contracts that the teams
regret jared goff three turnovers called
out by sean mcveigh who never calls out
anyone i feel like mcveigh's kind of
getting to his wits end here not that he
can really do anything about it they are
tied
to goff for at least the next couple of
years so uh yeah
uh jared goff three turnovers a game
they should have won
changes the vibe dramatically about the
rams right now goff is the reason for it
he gets the goat horns yeah i i uh i
understand that i do um it's hard that
was probably gonna be my next pick
actually i'm pissed i didn't take that
number one to have that uh i didn't
think you were gonna go back-to-back
quarterback on me all
right uh i think i'm gonna go with brady
next you know i i again
with brady the stats look pretty good i
get that but it was too late you know
too little too late
the game was the damage had been done
and a lot of the damage was done by him
and again i know people are sitting
there going to defend everything at
every last straw and i know he's you
know the most accomplished quarterback
ever and everybody thinks he's the
greatest of all time i just evaluated
what i'm seeing right now and when you
get all those third and fives and less
and you throw two you know two
interceptions when hey it's 27 to 10
they got the ball twice and went down
the field and you're going whoa
and he throws two interceptions that you
know made it of course that much harder
so yeah i'm gonna give brady the uh the
goat horns this week and uh he'll he's
my second pick
i i was torn between brady and bruce
erians because i look i think brady has
handled himself extremely perfect
definitely in this whole
strange passive aggressive who are we
blaming aggressive who are we blaming
it's clear that bruce arians has an
issue that he's talking about publicly
and maybe he's talking about it
privately and brady is just going about
his business and if that fight ever
comes to a head brady is going to win
because he's the guy they want back next
year if they had to choose between the
two it's going to be brady all right
last one for me i went with quarterback
who played quarterback who played i'm
now going to go with three quarterbacks
who didn't play drew lock
brett rippon
and blake borders that's right for
whatever it is that happened in that
meeting room last week that got them
knocked out of the game because jeff
driscoll tested positive
those guys look and i think that maybe
the allegations against the broncos have
been trumped up a little bit by a league
office that likes to blame any failures
not on the plan but on the execution of
the plan by the teams i think that uh
regardless of that the those three
quarterbacks deserve the blame for the
broncos having no quarterbacks on sunday
yeah um i i hear that that's um that's a
tough one you know i had to do that
yesterday no no qb no winnie okay in
denver you don't have a qb you're not
gonna play good okay so that was
unbelievable my next one i'm going back
to a team thing again all right i'll go
to gruden and derek carr gruden and
derek carr i'm just pick those two all
right but i mean really the whole effort
by the raiders that was embarrassing but
especially their offense i mean this is
a falcons defense that's certainly been
better under raheem morris i understand
that but to just get two field goals and
have all those mistakes and turnovers
and lay an egg a week after you look so
good against the chiefs that was
disappointing to me so they'll be my
last pick for the draft
that that is a disqualifying loss that
is the kind of thing where you should
just say they're out of the playoff
picture all together i would love to
have that power to say sorry with a game
like that lost two people don't get in
even if you win the rest of your games
that that alone where are you gonna have
them in your power rankings this week
mike we'll find out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports